- Ricky?
- [Ricky] Yo.
- Here.
- What's that?
- A switch.
- That's right.
- Yes.
- So apparently you can
shut off the stream of
your sperm just like a light switch.
- Yeah?
That makes sense.
- Let's see what people on
the street think about that.
(drums playing)
- So a German invention just recently
released a device that you can turn
off the flow of your sperm.
- Wow, really?
- Yeah.
- They just developed something
that stops the flow of sperm?
- Yes.
- That's bad news.
- But like a light switch
you can turn it on and off.
- Oh cool.
- You goin out, this is not the young
lady that you want to spend
the rest of your life with.
You turn this thing off.
- Yeah
- [Host] Yeah yeah yeah
- I gotta cut the flow off.
- Yep gotta cut it off.
- The woman of your life, boom.
- Yep.
Then it's go time!
(laughter)
- Yep!
- I feel like this is a great idea.
You can choose when you want to have kids.
- I think if you have the power to do that
and it's in your control, are you ready to
recreate, reproduce
- [Man] Yeah!
- And that's fantastic.
- That's a really good question
so it's going through the
trial period right now.
They're looking for people to try it out
to bring it to market.
- [Interviewee] Right right.
- Would you be willing to be one of those
men willing to try this thing out?
- Well first of all I'll
try just about anything
but that's kinda a stretch.
- Sure why not?
I mean we only live once right?
- Yeah.
- So why not let's try it.
- I dig that.
- No, not at all.
- Really?
- Yeah I don't want anybody messing
with my joint, my joint is primal.
- But you like the idea?
- Well the idea, but just not for me.
- No.
- Nah I wouldn't.
- I wouldn't.
- So my thing is this
do what's safe
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Do what's mature
you know, and do what
what allows you to continue and enjoy
the beautiful aspect of lovemaking.
- You got that kids?
- There it is.
- On, off.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- Hell yeah you can
control pregnancies now!
(laughter)
I love it!